herzlich willkommen zu meinen heutigen
video leute ich bin heute nicht bei mir
der grund sondern ich bin wie ihr
vielleicht sondern hintergrund erkennt
bei sturm ii zu gast denn schumi hat
dieses wunderbare etwas von ihr werde es
wahrscheinlich schon dem titel gelesen
haben bier bestellen heute eine pizza
mit glücksrad das wird folgendermaßen
funktionieren dieses glücks 114 felder
auf sieben felder schreiben der gute
zutaten und auch sieben weitere felder
so die weniger guten zutaten ich habe so
eine pizza lieferservice gefunden da
kann man sich eine pizza komplett von
grund auf sand stellen und ihr seht
schon japan anders artischocken wohl um
diese broccoli currysauce extra käse
richtig an schreibt mir die portale
wissen wer gerade reingekommen ist
außerdem büros ab was auch immer das ist
kann meist eh schon es gibt jede menge
sachen und wir überlegen uns erstmal was
sie alles drauf schreiben glaube die
guten sachen kriegt man wahrscheinlich
auch sony sie aus dem kopf zusammen oder
also eine gute sache studie ist dass
hinter der kamera etwas erledigen muss
die journalisten haslacher hassel am
lack abonniert auch stürmer für einen
sagen sie halt auch mal salami so das
ist klassisch das würde ich schon raus
was war das schweigen ist nichts für
dich hin dass alle hebel fahrer dann
sagen wir das ist glaube ich das beste
einfach käse also bzw extra käse
schinken er stieß auf kritik
und bei den schlechten sachen muss mich
dann gleich
frieren lassen tut wird ja also das wird
dann auch schon spielt immer voller hass
thunfisch schinken uns haben jedoch 100
wenn es dann so nahe des spiels wird
sagt ich höre mir hast du warten aber
ich bin mit tomaten sind daher die
politik leben wir noch und rucola und
kuba aber das ist eher schlecht
ok dann regeln für dich noch als gute
zutaten oblau und jetzt leute geht an
die eklige sachen also schauen wir mal
nehmen wir mal probieren also brokkoli
ist unsere ersten schlechte zutaten wie
viele likes in diesem moment gerade da
las selbst übrigens oft drehen also wenn
ihr jetzt gerade fünf lifestyle laster
geld natürlich niemand bei uns oder papa
nur kaputt findet ganz übel meiner
meinung nach nichts zu suchen so holland
des portals es schlimm dass man sowohl
even oliven finde ich persönlich auch
schlimm für rohes fleisch und zuletzt
party schaffen wir drehen jetzt fünf mal
und ich verstehe dann die pizza die am
ende dabei herauskommt als erstes der
zählt jetzt noch nicht green day
mitmachen
habt ihr verstanden weil der song geht
ebenso antreten
also 3 2 1
knoblauch okay du findest knoblauch gut
knoblauch ok als erstes tier kostet
sogar nicht mal als bürgerbus inklusive
sparsamen länger der nächsten 3-4 habe
broccoli nach dem kirner unter
valentinus geht das geht steht zunächst
andrea kaum tomaten finde ich gut
aktuell sind wir gerade bei sonne werde
bei einer gemüse pizza
du darfst das nächste training zutaten
nummer drei freunde wird käse oder damit
war der findest dich die normalsten
sachen schlimm nächstes unter experten
ist auch im staat ist der vierte dreier
jetzt nämlich brave gleich wenn die
leute noch das okay wir haben heute ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt schlechtes aber
durch sehr groß ist auch drin
schinken gyros sinken
ich glaube das ist so eine pizza die
wirklich nur ausgeliefert wird der mann
stand im voraus bezahlte ja das würde
ich auch immer das ist so wie bist du
krank bist ja gleich kommt zu der der
pizzafahrer und sagt so drin videos das
war erst das fünfte mal eben kurz wir
müssen jetzt abwarten
ich glaube jetzt wird vielleicht der
letzte drehtag habe und werde noch
schlimm aber ich finde salami im bus ist
auch schwerer salami schinken und gyros
besonders die ekelhafteste perversion
stylist schokolade gibt halt und
peperoni salami oder rinder seien noch
keine salami der schon wieder kein
bisschen scharf dafür wie salat salat
macht du bestimmt gleich soweit wir sind
dabei 14 eur 80 gelandet das hier ist
unsere pizza gyros puten schinken tomate
pepperoni salami broccoli extra käse und
knoblauch nicht gerade wie 57 mal
getötet danke dass ihr so viele leichte
fragen wir sie mal bringen ich bin
glaube ich die ganze zeit in eine
bildschirmaufnahme reingehen aber ich
war dabei okay vielleicht meinen kanal
machen noch eine normale pizza dazu
ja es stimmt dass du ja wenn ich
tatsächlich in lebenstedt geil
dann nehmen wir nochmal stinkend jetzt
dazu ist gut so aber vorläufig nicht zur
pizza detail normalität
mit dieser karte bedeutet gemacht die
bestellung fertig und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder wenn der pizzalieferant
klingelt wenn es sehr sehr gespannt und
wird bestimmt sehr lecker
denn für ein witz so schneider zwischen
den beiden schüttelt wisst ihr das
bedeutet wie pizza ist angekommen
projekt wollen wir einfach mal gemeinsam
reinschauen 321 sieht gar nicht so
schlecht erstaunlich passant sprang nur
warum haben die in einem pizza ladentür
ort überhaupt weil die machen
chinesische schnitzel
aber das ist immer schlecht mache alles
was das ok dann natürlich die tomaten
das ist schon mal schlecht gerechnet
dass dann haben wir was wir haben
juli jede menge käse hier sehr nah wie
zalando handvoll ansatz der während
eines 24 scheiben salami ihr einfach
bonus die waren sich die roten kommen
erfolg ist auch wissen die haben noch
eine normale spitze bestellt einfach
und ratet mal welche pizza 15 und welche
neuen euro gekostet 15 euro also macht
es zu hause nicht nato dafür hat der
behinderte speisten im internet die
sowas testen und wir probieren jetzt
einfach mal die glücksrad pizza ich
schneide zu für alle ok also die leute
werden hier die ich jetzt treten wir die
ganze zeit eine ziemlich langweilig
wirklich diese zeit verwenden kann und
mein video auf das kind das gerne einen
kommentare welche hitze war meine
lieblings pizza ist glaube ich das hier
genannt brokkoli büro schinken salami
torwart babos wetter geht es nicht
weiter wir haben jetzt noch zwei stück
meine lieblings pizza zudem geiles und
mit soko larissa nico und vielleicht so
parmaschinken dass es sich immer mal
richtig verschenken das kriegt mich dann
sofort das ist etwas besonderes weil so
pizza perse ist schon das ein oder
andere mal auf dem teller ist ja aber
bei mir nicht ich bin natur dick als
standard zahlreich glaube ich auch mit
am liebsten so ne pizza prosciutto cotto
[Musik]
gerechnet für die voliere tomatenessenz
tust du
weil das so ist jetzt bildet machen
ich habe so ein richtig schön beladen
ist steckt wenn man dann die so im
querschnitt
stimmt dann ist immer in salami schinken
bitte das ist für diese schicht oder es
ist einfach teig dann kommt sie in
salami schinken dann kommt käse und dann
kommt also dann sind es ne lass dir
schmecken habe ich hunger
das ist richtig schaden von kunden am
gießener musik von maxi aus und sie
halten gerade ich kann meinen ist jetzt
auch überraschend gut aber ich habe auch
noch nicht so viel dabei er schmeckt
echt gut das beste also dass ich jemals
hier gekocht habe es nicht so schwer ist
wenn ihr wissen wollt was nicht gut war
was ich habe dann startet die herzog
sein kann aber ist natürlich verdient
überraschend gut ich hätte ja das passt
irgendwie nicht ich auch nicht das passt
perfekt zusammen hier schreiben heute
hat es ist die pizza supreme ii kader
gibt es bei jedem italiener ihr idioten
52 diese krise ist ja eh nicht und für
die planung
[Musik]
also ja ich meine wer mehr speicher
stück gegessen
ich muss wirklich sagen ich hätte nicht
erwartet dass das so gut schmeckt
irgendwie würdest du zu einem zu einem
etwas
also man schmeckt gar nicht so die
einzelnen vielleicht gar nicht
zusammenpassen in sachen wollte ich weiß
auch nicht wie man so viel glück haben
kann bei sieben mal drehen so wenig
scheiße zu erwischen
also für mich schon also eigentlich war
es in salalah mich schrecklich suchen
die vielleicht auf tomaten dass man
überlegen was wir hätten haben können
werden kann
so soll einer der ersten ruck und und
schinken habe ich eine gute kombination
hatte ich eigentlich hätten wir so
machen müssen dass wir eine bestellen
und sieben sachen die wir die was machen
und darf die andere kommen die anderen
aber so was war denn wir hatten
offensichtlich glücklich so scharf
mitbringen es ist eher die salami für
die wird auf jeden fall auf die gäste
lagen 75 ps nicht wirklich ob und wie
sonst ganz groß was dazu sagen wollt ihr
dass wir heute vielleicht mehr die dort
heute gebiet seit zwei davon machen
werdet sehen dass dort bald mit höheren
gerichten geht ermitteln und reis aber
auch mit sauce hollandaise und was dazu
okay heute das mit einem anderen gericht
hat schon die kommentare und wir sehen
uns dann macht's gut